shoppers are getting their second win
after a record-setting season some
forecasts expect today to be the fourth
busiest shopping day of 2017 as much as
30 percent of this year's retail sales
are made during the holiday season early
estimates show holiday shoppers spent a
record 598 billion dollars that is up 33
billion with the beat from last year
online shopping surged 18.1% Charisse
Jones covers business and the economy
for USA Today and she joins us now good
morning good morning
so Charisse can these record numbers
over the holiday season tell us anything
about how consumers will spend next year
I think so I mean I think people are
feeling a lot more confident about the
economy I mean wages are up a little bit
unemployment is very low we've got a tax
bill that's coming down the pike and so
this is any indication people are
feeling a lot more encouraged they're
not worried so much about being buried
in debt and retailers have gotten very
smart about rolling out lots of
discounts and sales and that's a prime
motivator as well so this season was
really hot and I think next year could
be good as well so what are some of the
best selling gifts this holiday season
you know home-improvement materials of
all things were really hot sellers the
insta pot which is like a steamer and a
pressure cooker all and obviously toys
were a big seller the fingerling is a
little palm sized monkey that you can
touch and make it move and people love
what it is a palm size monkey yeah it's
called a fingerling and it's adorable
and it kind of moves around and you know
it's animated and so people really love
that electronics are always a hot seller
so the 4k TVs are flying off the shelves
so pretty much every category did well
but those were some of the hottest
sellers you mentioned flying off the
shelves and the one big thing they had
was this extra Saturday going into
Christmas so how much did Super Saturday
or how did Super Saturday compared to
Black Friday Super Saturday was close to
Black Friday the last two years has
actually been the biggest shopping day
of the year this year it was a little
bit less than Black Friday but you still
had about a hundred and twenty six
million people you know procrastinators
who headed out to buy something so it
it's a really big day for the retail
industry as well and we know that more
than half of Americans did their
shopping online how does this in fact
affect the brick-and-mortar store
specifically against Amazon you know
brick-and-mortar stores you know a sale
as a sale as a sale I mean Amazon gets a
lot of online sales but all of these
different retailers have their own
websites as well so if a dollar is spent
online or at an actual brick-and-mortar
location it's going into the same pot
and it all feeds the bottom line so
they're happy either way and we read
anything based on online sales around
holidays for online sales just in
general going into next year yeah
they're really surging I mean 18 percent
cyber monday was the biggest online
shopping day in history with more than
six billion dollars in sales so that's
really accelerating but most sales still
happen at natural stores so they're not
going to be going out of business any
time soon as you heard at the top of the
show we've been talking about very cold
weather for a large portion of the
country does that impact people shopping
behavior I mean malls are tend to be
warm you can go out and get your winter
clothing and so I think people like the
you know the social atmosphere of going
out and shopping and so I don't think
the cold weather will be an impediment
unless the roads are really bad and then
eventually it'll get better and they'll
get back out what about gift cards I
mean the National Retail Federation says
twenty eight billion dollars was spent
on gift cards that's usually what I give
to a lot of people readily popular
because you can do what you want with it
you just have to read the fine print to
make sure it's not going to expire most
don't you have at least five years to
use them but you want to check because
some retailers have gone out of business
I mean if you have a Sports Authority
card you know you're out of luck yeah so
you want to be able to get out there and
use it or lose it a good indicator
though on consumer confidence which has
been at record highs as of late so it's
a good indicator going in to the new
year about where Americans stand on the
economy they're feeling a lot better you
know they think that things are looking
up and they've got jobs and they're
spending well Charisse Jones thank you
so much for coming in Happy Holidays
Vlad I will be expecting my gift
exactly a lot of work labs gonna be
doing these few days